SPEAKER: Gary was a crop duster.
(AIRPLANES WHOOSHING)
SPEAKER 2: And the best pilot
the TOPGUN program
had ever known.
That's my dad.
SPEAKER: He walked away
from 11 plane crashes.
SPEAKER 3:
A special kind of wild man.
(AIRPLANE WHOOSHES)
SPEAKER: One morning,
when I'm driving to the country,
the car had broken down,
and all of a sudden...
Gary jumped off the bridge.
(LIGHTNING CRACKS)
SPEAKER 4:
What made him do that?
(LIGHTNING CRACKS)
SPEAKER 5:
People had, like, theories.
(LIGHTNING CRACKS)
SPEAKER 6:
I know it was a shock...
(LIGHTNING CRACKS)
SPEAKER 6: ...but maybe
it wasn't inexplicable.
I didn't think they talked
about our double life.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER 7: Gary became
an international drug smuggler,
and he had made millions
and millions of dollars.
SPEAKER: It gets complicated.
Your mind has to switch gears.
But I never once told the kids.
His wife ought to have
an Academy Award.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
The war on drugs intensified
during that time.
In the end, this was almost like
the tip of the iceberg.
SPEAKER 8: Gary was flying
guns connected to the CIA.
(ON RECORDING)
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
SPEAKER 9:
My expectations were so high
of my dad
that it broke me.
SPEAKER 10: You're part
of what she experienced.
SPEAKER 11: When you're dealing
with that kind of money,
people act different.
SPEAKER 12: I don't think
Gary Betzner had a clue
of what he was tripping into...
♪ (MUSIC BUILDS) ♪
SPEAKER 12: ...one of
the biggest political scandals
of his lifetime.
♪ (MUSIC PLAYS, FADES) ♪